[Music]
hey have you ever heard of the Legacy
leagues yeah duh what's that what is
that it's a it's a basketball league
that you might love dude I know all
about this man the big leag no Legacy
league is it just like for old people
you never heard of Legacy League show
them tell them tell me I didn't know you
were into basketball I you like
basketball I like basketball I like the
way they driple up and down the court
record highlights of every game and have
full stats including box scores League
leaders you can join this league look
what's different what's different about
it we have who is that F Duncan oh it's
a 8ot
rim right they lower the rims yeah it's
a rim on League hey we've been advertis
we've been saying they should do this
they do
interviews they have stats they have
real teams with jerseys guys are
fighting for sure
D but the rim is 8 and 1/2t feet the
Filipino leag so everyone can dunk and
there's a there's a height limit of 6'4
oh that's can't be taller than 6'4 damn
so I wouldn't make it cuz I'm 6'4 and a
half sorry dude damn you can't play like
that [__] hey
you're why is it called Legacy
League um I think they just like the
name they thought it sounded cool cuz a
legacy means it's been around for a long
time wait this is real they should call
it the new the new league isn't this
like self-proclaim you're a [__]
that's the debate yeah oh really it's
like hey I'm a professional boxer but in
my organization you can only have
pillows and you can't hit too hard well
some people say boxing is already
pillows some people call that uh let me
think it sounds fun to me yeah let's
look at both sides cuz there's a side
that's like hey that's cool now
everybody can dunk the games are pretty
fun it it looks cool in some way have
something that against accessibility in
some ways yeah sounds like training
wheels for professional like a
professional BX I think for basketball
it's just not a good look bro I think uh
there all there are also like videos
going out where like people are dunking
and then afterwards going yeah I don't
like that I don't unless they were like
super super short like two feet yeah
like that's not that's if you throw off
the backboard and you 360 whill it you
know like and I think that's cool for
you to do all that stuff cuz you know
you're just dunking on 8 and 1/2 foot
Rim official price it's not
that be
because I think orange Rim do you guys
like when they edit a sport to kind of
make it a little more I love it I think
it's
cool first wait think about this think
about this you know why no no you know
why you know why think about like K1 or
like uh cart racing you know what I'm
talking about that's not [__] NASCAR
F1 but but at the same time when people
do that legit it's [__] still sick
that's the pussiest [__] you ever seen
bro you're not watching people go to K1
watch you see someone [__] taking a
turn like
the [__] reference a better reference
there's people who play tennis and
Tennis is gamer and then you got [__]
pingpong I thought about that but it's
not the same that's not the same that's
not the same it's like it's like this
it's like if if like like people that
were washed up from high school they're
grown men playing on a Little League
field as opposed to a real League size
field men are still taking a little ass
rack and a little ball over a net with a
same [__] concept can I my
turn you tickle
to get his arm down your hand went down
your hand went down legally your hand
went down see Sports is right here right
okay Sports is here people are trying to
lower the standard uhhuh I liked it when
people rais the standard give the
baseball player steroids yes please
remember remember [__] Pride it's a
spectrum though there it goes both ways
LeBron James steroids now see what
happens but also I want to see some
crazy [__]
WNBA needs to lower the rims it's the
same [__] look look look look
look these gu yeah these guys are grown
men they're grown men but they can't be
more than 6'4 that's fine you know what
Anthony wants to do he wants to put a
blanket over his head and then have
light a [__] match and go oh this is
the fourth of July show this
so that you want to bring the world
smaller I'm sitting over here this guy's
an
idiot Steve come over here dude this is
the fourth of July to bring the world
smaller I want to make the world bigger
sucks that's like the worst show ever
these guys can we have both no no no
these both these guys are doing this
league purely for the reason so they
could dunk that's the only reason why
they're doing this league what if they
come out with cool dunk Styles like the
Harlem Globe trots then they should do
the even they play on a 10 Court still
doesn't wouldn't give enough time to do
trampoline dunking is superior I think
to NBA I'm down with that cuz the
world's bigger it's way more so for B
it's like you can't lower the rim you
can only go up so if you're going to go
up you can use trampolines hey remember
during the during the '90s when we were
growing up not you Nick but us the rest
of us mostly I grew up in the '90s was a
little you remember Mel do you remember
the Jordan Mania you remember Jordan
being like basically Jesus Christ at the
time I knew Michael Jordan was a very
big D are you that young cuz I watched
fireworks under a blanket with a [__]
lighter so check this out you had to
watch the Bulls to watch the electricity
of the NBA back then y you you but now
imagine a world where every team is the
Bulls yeah trampoline Howard all these
players are dunking the [__] out of the
ball you have a whole new Talent let's
go now way more talent and then guess
what people are going to watch NBA more
by the way NBA Revenue sucks NBA the the
the show on television sucks mostly I
know some big NBA fans out there that's
nice but guess what the revenue sucks
okay you guys are are sucking dick okay
cuz to me the way I see it upgrade
there's a difference between heavyweight
boxing yep and then the featherweight
the lighter guys they go fast and [__]
and then the big guys big [__] power
so we need we need [__]
basketball a smaller ball we need [__]
basketball a biger hoop smaller ball
bigger hoop more hops get the
trampolines in there right cheerleaders
cheerleaders that big HT only only
jumping only jump what about slam ball
isn't that a thing that's the thing
that's the trampoline League oh okay I'm
advocating for it but should integrated
what about a new league where you're
using rocket
packs all right dud
genius that's cooler than the Legacy
League I think so so rocket none of you
guys has respect for this league except
Anthony I'm not saying I have respect
for it I'm just saying I'm not thinking
it's like the most cuck thing in the
world I think it's a good way to like
burn callers and hang out with your
friends yeah I serious it just seems
like you know the guys at 24-Hour
Fitness that are mad serious when
they're playing just the people that are
like they wouldn't play in this
league all I'm saying is not everybody's
good enough to be in the NBA so you need
a spot for some people to go it's not
about them being good doesn't mean
people want to watch there's so many
leagues though there's so many adult
nobody's watching there's not even
bleachers hey guess where people go when
they don't make in the NFL car
dealerships should people watch it what
the [__] are you talking
about should people should we have to
watch people try to sell cars who were
wide receivers last week no if they had
a place that they could still JJ news is
like a D League Comedy Channel come on
oh that's what I thought [__] he way
too high we're like [__] e f League F
League we're too we're like the the the
athletes Watchers they watch us and then
they get inspiration but we're too
highbrow name one [__] athlete wait
what Michael Jordan that watches us and
gets
inspiration Deon Sanders would never
admit he watches the show yeah Dion
Sanders watches the show hella for
sure all
right all this is is a bunch of dudes
like us that said wouldn't it be dope if
we can all dunk and then they made it
happen and they made a league out of it
and they're just having a great time I'm
like how is that any different from what
we do yeah then why are we talking [__]
on that I never talk [__] about that L
listen listen we're on a show where we
have some people who are not that smart
right and and but it helps because we
can dunk on those people like for
example the dancers we can dunk on whoa
no no no not not you you going to take
that no
danc this guy was in Battle of the Year
with Chris Brown man most epic I just
found out he's a dancer like tonight I
don't
remember yeah I was reminded I drix is
just drix for me I I I only met drix
here I never met drix outside of here
see so he's just D see fail YouTuber in
this yeah this is this guy's the dancer
and that's he's a champion but guess who
guess when the fans get together and
they have a great time and we love our
fans on the show even he loves the fans
two words Bubble Bobble no no no the no
the fans love to meme that Anthony's
head is a big orange basketball getting
dunked and that's the point people enjoy
it it's a sport in wait until they make
[__] Bubble Bobble viral
right they they shouldn't do it they
shouldn't do it you're watching a man be
graped live I'll take the [__] orange
basketball head wait until we got the
blue cheek dinosaur you're watching
great life I hope you're enjoying show
enjoy the show do we support it or we
don't I think it's I honestly think it's
pretty endearing I think it's cute did
you see the way that they're filming the
games and they have stats and they do
interiew it's like real Sports they're
trying to make it real it's all just
with phones I love it kind of cute so
bad if I was in the league these guys
feel dude you have you guys ever played
an adult basketball men's league before
no yeah on a regular Rim I hate them
it's fun but also there's a part of that
feels like I should be doing something
else I think if anybody said that what I
was doing was was cute and it's I'm
trying to take it seriously I'd probably
quit yeah yeah yeah it is it's nothing
but cute it's like literally the chibi
of basketball you know what sucks what's
chibi it's like little cute Japanese
character yeah yeah that's how I see it
that's why it makes me feel sad for them
but I didn't think they were taking it
Ser that's why I thought this was fun
just don't the a bunch of guys get
together to do fun [__] they dunk when
they have the like look at that whose
house is this that's the part that's
funny yeah it gets a little it looks a
little like laring basketball to me
you're mixing up what's going on that's
like pool basketball as Fu so I don't
know what you're talking about wait what
wait I said it what's your what's your
real reaction that's the guy who won
slam dunk cont they slam dunk content is
it not
cute his wait that's real his team's
called the ice trays check it out a joke
no that he won the slam dunk contest
guys see this they have a slam dunk
contest this League's just [__]
trolling dud yeah but look at the trophy
let me see let me see this picture the
trophy says it all you can't hate on
that it's not like he's getting a
[__] million dollar check I call the
hoop is lower and the trophy is lower
too even he's not satisfied even he
knows it's a joke here let me I honestly
think that my cell phone battery is
bigger than the whole trophy let him
play coach
trophy if you were in a basketball
league would you rather play on a 8ot
rim or the 10ft standard 10 foot
standard bro I do 4 foot because that's
just the basketball that I want to play
these guys want to play a different
basketball as all would you look down on
them like like 8 foot bar look at your
phone I sent you the winning dunk of the
B of the slam dunk contest for this
league let me get your real reaction a
[__] show like this in distance if
you laugh if you laugh you've taken away
The
credibility oh he's about to grab it
from the rim and then dunk
it
yeah that's
cool how come no one's
there that's the dunk contest nobody's
there wait saying nobody's already there
we're just you guys are just trying to
kick them while they're already wait is
that a WNBA video send me that hey hey
hey being honest though even if it was 8
and half ft would any of us really be
able to still I still don't think I
could dunk I definitely kid T I'd be
able to well not you Steve wait no I'm
I'm questioning you're banned you're
banned I don't want to hyp myself DK 8
and2 because it's 8 and 1/2 ft there's
tons of full court shots too in this
game full court shot holy yeah dude
people are pulling up from [__] the
other side I don't like about it the
fact that they hate on people that are
over 6'4 that tells you
enough it's shaming it's
shaming